Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you Ruffians for joining us today for our 68th episode!
That's a lot of episodes!
I feel like just a few weeks ago we were, oh, it's episode 36.
Right?
It just kind of hit me today.
Wow.
68 episodes.
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
Well, for Ruffians that may be, today's your first FUWAMOCO Morning.
Well, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short-format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
AKA FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag, hashtag, FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
You missed us!
Hasn't been that long though.
Has it?
I definitely did.
Moco-chan.
Ruffians.
Did you notice anything strange?
There's been some bad news.
There's been!
Another Pero Sighting.
Well, let's hear where he was spotted today.
De-den!
The Pero's become hot chocolate!
I don't know, that's actually pretty fitting, no?
He looks great here!
Pretty nice.
Actually, pretty delicious even.
That's pretty amazing!
Appetizing!
Yeah, that's amazing for a nasty guy like him.
You know, I like how his sweater looks a bit sleepy.
It must be because, you know, he's all warm and toasty.
Nice!
It's like a big bath.
I'm a bit envious.
But you know,
FUWAMOCO
Why haven't I been made into a Mococo yet, Ruffians?
I wanna be warm and toasty too, okay?
Warm milk, nice mug.
Sounds pretty good.
I just wanna be a warm cup of Mococo.
I wanna be warm!
Yeah!
Well, you know, it's definitely the season for some comfy, warm drinks.
It's cold, right, Ruffians?
Careful what you ask for, Mococo.
What?
Moco-chan just wants to be a warm drink.
I didn't want to warm you up!
Okay.
Well, we hope you enjoyed your, uh...
Pero, even though he deflated a little bit.
That's okay.
That's okay, yeah.
He still looks like he was delicious!
And that's what's important, right.
But, Ruffians!
What do you think of a FUWAMOCO cafe, huh?
Cafe, huh?
FUWAMOCO cafe.
Yeah, you have your, uh, your FUWAMORNING!
Topped with a moco chest.
And a FUWAMOCO loco moco.
Right.
BAU BAU BAU!
Lots of ideas!
Fuwa latte!
Fuwa water!
Fuwa waffles!
Fuwa watame!
Right!
That's a thought.
You think that?
Yeah.
The cafe attendants would be cute.
Well, they have to wear ears and tail too, right?
They have to say BAU BAU, right?
Otherwise they're fired!
I like talking over ice, but... Oh!
Oh, us?
Oh, we work at the cafe?
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
We're not gonna fire ourselves.
No!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
There's been another milestone!
No misunderstanding!
Another milestone!
It started with an M, but it's different.
This one's happy.
Yeah.
Wow.
Our cover of Kanaya's Identity has hit 500,000 views!
BAU BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Wow!
Mocobaby appears.
That was what you just said.
Wow!
That's what the Ruffians said.
Ruffians, you know, it makes us really happy to think that our singing has been able to reach so many.
You know, hopefully, maybe in the process, it's made a few new Ruffians too.
You know, we know it's just a cover song, but we feel really happy and hope that, you know,
In the future, maybe our original music can do the same too!
We'll continue to sing loud tonight!
Thank you, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Very exciting.
But also, on the topic of music, Ruffians!
You haven't forgotten about the new hololive English cover song, right?
BAU!
But you know what?
It was originally set to release at the beginning of the month, but now it will be releasing on January 20th at 7pm PT or 12 noon JST on the 21st.
Excited!
I'm really excited for you, Shiori.
It's very colorful, very emotional.
You know, and we're just so thankful to Bae-senpai for including us in Advent too!
You know, we kind of talk about how FUWAMOCO, we still just kind of feel like... Somehow we're here!
Somehow!
We're still here!
Yeah, but Minecraft, you know, it kind of makes us feel like, oh!
We're in hololive now!
So, it really means a lot to us.
Thank you very much!
Please look forward to it, okay, Ruffians?
Yeah, five days, six... Five days, six days.
Like, what day is it?
You'll blink and it'll be here, Ruffians.
Yeah, sleep a bit, it'll be here.
Alright.
Okay.
I know maybe joining FUWAMOCO for some fun times.
Yeah!
It'll be here.
Okay.
BAU BAU!
I'm so excited for you.
I hope we can do more songs altogether.
Right, I hope so.
There's a lot of work that goes into coordinating something like that.
Please look forward to it.
Ruffians, we sure are.
I have a bit of a quiz for you, okay?
Ruffians.
Do you know who these are?
Do you know?
You know who these are, right?
Yeah!
That's you, Ruffian!
It's you, it's you!
Ruffian!
Aren't you cute?
Very fluffy, very fuzzy, right?
A perfect size for hugging, huh?
For hugging.
Yeah, but you know there's a blue one and a pink one.
But they're both equally Ruffians.
You know there's a blue Ruffian and a pink Ruffian.
They have no names.
It's just describing the colors.
In case you couldn't tell, okay?
Pretty cool.
I think so too.
That's you!
That's you, yes!
Ruffian fuzzy, well that's the thing.
Equally Ruffians, you know?
There are no Ruffians, no fuzzians.
Just Ruffians, okay?
That's the thing.
Just Ruffians.
A Ruffian is a Ruffian is a Ruffian, okay?
It isn't Mococo's Ruffian or Fuwawa's Ruffian.
All Ruffians are both of our Ruffians, right?
We're sharing.
All Ruffians are both of our Ruffians, okay?
Cuz you know, just as we care about all of you, we want you to like and care about both of us too, okay?
You know...
I can love Moco-chan lots.
Really?
Yeah.
It's kind of embarrassing saying these things early in the morning.
It's hard to say it right on.
I love Fuwawa lots too, of course, but... You can tell from my actions, okay?
I don't need to say it because my actions say it.
Okay, got it.
Ruffians, we really want you to like both of us too, you know?
Taking sides and maybe putting one of us down, it makes both of us sad.
And that's because we both love each other very much.
And we hope that if you love one of us,
BAU BAU!
Pero is not a part of this, okay?
We said both of us.
No, pero.
Okay.
BAU BAU!
There's a lot of confessions going on.
Why?
BAU BAU.
This is not the confession corner, okay, Ruffians?
No!
No confession today!
Okay, okay.
What?
Well, Ruffians!
We got a scoop from one of you!
We got a scoop!
Thank you!
Thank you so much, Piotr, for the excellent journalism!
Well, it seems like...
Biboo and Calli-senpai, they had a collab the other day where they got talking about some of the Japanese words and phrases that we've taught Biboo.
And well, Calli-senpai!
Calli-senpai finally got to learn about my favorite Japanese word.
Ruffians, you remember what it is, right?
Why are you making that face and not giving me the answer like I asked, huh?
Otomari-kai.
A bit different, a bit different.
But, you know, Biboo then said the most recent phrase that we taught her in Japanese.
But, Kaori-senpai immediately thought the worst.
I mean, Biboo thinks that we tricked her again!
Kaori-senpai!
Again?
No!
Are you doubting us?
Don't misunderstand!
This nameru is not nameru like lick-nameru.
It's nameru like underestimate.
Two different meanings.
We discussed this on FUWAMOCO Morning already.
Yeah, okay.
What are you thinking things like that, huh?
Huh?
I think, if anything Ruffians, Calli-senpai is the one to be questing here, okay?
Yeah.
No fucking us on the nose, okay?
No!
We're innocent puppies!
Yeah.
No pain.
No.
Okay?
Accusing senpai?
I'm gonna accuse.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
I don't know, isn't that the role of a kouhai sometimes?
Right?
To accuse the senpai?
Exactly, that's a normal role.
Ruffians!
We also wanted to share some extra special trivia with you today about FUWAMOCO Morning!
Extra special trivia!
Because...
You know, we have the Extra Special Ruffian that we call out at the end of every FUWAMOCO Morning, right?
You know?
Well, actually, it was Mama Puppy that gave us that idea.
You know, back when Mama Puppy was a wee little puppy herself, there was a TV show that she liked that used to do something similar.
You know, she used to watch it almost every morning.
But she always thought it was so exciting and lovely, and she couldn't wait to get her name called out.
But you know, of course, there's no comment section.
So every day, she'd wait in hopes that Mama Puppy would be called.
Yeah!
Yeah.
That's the origins of it.
You know, because we're live here with you.
I can see your names.
No matter how unique your name is, we can read it.
We can read it, okay.
Even if your name is... Momomountainlove65 or something.
We can still read it.
We can still see it.
Yeah, we can see your names.
The Slayer.
Wiggles.
You know it.
Yeah, we can read it.
We hope that it can bring you savage foils.
Just as much happiness and excitement as you know it did for Mama Puppy when she was a little puppy.
But you know, even if her name isn't called for a long time, please remember, Ruffians, that you're still extra special to us no matter what.
We see you.
We do.
We see you here.
We see you on Twitter.
We see you.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
It's that time of the week!
You've forgotten about it.
It's time for Moco-chan to challenge herself to something new.
And today, that's eating natto!
It's been three weeks.
It's been on a bit of a hiatus, but it's back!
I don't want to spill.
I have a nice new outfit.
You're not gonna spill.
But Ruffians, you know what?
If you challenge yourself to something new at the beginning of the week, you can do anything!
Nothing is scary!
Or at the beginning of the year, but I hope you challenge yourself more than just once this year.
Can you not mix it up this time?
No, I'm gonna mix it up!
But Ruffians, you can do!
You can do anything if you apply yourself to it.
That's why Moco-chan is going to show you that you can eat natto.
The last couple times you did pretty well Moco-chan.
Moco-chan ate a good amount of natto thanks to the sesame oil, right?
So, I believe in you today too, Moco-chan.
You can do it!
For any Ruffians that maybe don't know what natto is, natto is a Japanese breakfast food.
It's fermented soybeans, and it's pretty sticky and slimy, a little bit smelly.
But it's really, really good for you.
And Moco-chan, you do want to eat this eventually.
I do want to eat it.
That's why I'm challenging it, because I feel like there is value to eating it.
But I want to be able to eat it.
And eat it.
Happily ever after.
Okay.
So, baby steps.
You can do it, Moco-chan.
See, Moco-chan?
Yeah.
That's why I'm challenging you, because I want to do it!
And Moco-chan, you know, she's going to conquer her dislike for natto, so you know, hopefully, you can continue to protect the Ruffian smiles for many, many years to come, just like Fuwawa, right?
Because I ate my natto.
I'm mixing it up.
Oh, it's very sticky today.
Ruffians, we have the sesame oil on standby.
But Moco-chan said that she'd try it.
I don't have it.
Oh, I do have a tissue.
Just like normal.
And then we'll see if we need the sesame oil to make an appearance.
FUWAMOCO-chan.
Do you think you're ready?
Are you confident?
It's been three weeks.
I'm confident for you.
Okay well, Moco-chan.
First, let's say thank you to the farmers in Tochigi who worked very hard to make this.
Thank you.
I appreciate your farming.
I appreciate the farming.
Okay, Moco-chan!
Oh gosh.
It's very sticky today, huh?
It's really sticky.
Hai!
Itadakimasu!
Mada.
Mada?
Why is it so sticky?
It's very sticky, huh?
Oh, what?
It's too sticky.
Too sticky.
Yeah, it's making me... Making me what?
Confused.
Extra sticky today.
And the beans have a bit of a... A darker color?
Yeah.
I don't know why.
These are still good, right?
They're good!
Okay.
Here, Moco-chan has one bean.
Are you sure there's not a white spot on them?
That's the natto bean, extra good for you.
Okay!
No, just pinch your nose.
Okay.
Okay!
I'm concerned.
It's good, it's extra good for you.
Okay, here goes Moco-chan!
It was almost on the tongue and then it wasn't.
I feel like I may be doing better though.
Oh, are you?
It went in my mouth and then it went out.
That's apparently better.
What is... Oh!
Almost there.
Oh, oh!
It's left the chopsticks!
Pokemoco-chan, you're making too big of a deal out of this.
Oh, they just... Just let it out.
Just eat it and scream it out.
Huh?
You swallowed it?
Did you chew it?
No?
Ah.
Thank you.
One bean?
Ways different today.
In a good way.
I don't know.
She did it!
One bean straight.
Straight natto.
Okay, Moco-chan.
No, no, no, no, no.
You have to do another one.
No, I'm good.
I'm good.
No, you can't just put a paw there.
No, I'm good for now.
Thank you.
One more!
No, no.
Look!
No.
One more, Moco-chan.
Why?
It tastes different today.
Yeah, that's a good thing.
We believe in you.
I know what it's supposed to be.
One more bean, Moco-chan.
No.
One more bean for Poruru-oneechan.
Not this time.
Next week.
Next week!
I'll have the encore bean then.
Oh, this is so sticky!
Why?
I'm trying to pick one bean, but look, I have three!
Three encores!
Triple encore!
They're really good today.
They taste different.
Like, uh... BAU BAU!
Darker.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
You should try some natto too, okay?
Don't forget to challenge yourself to something new this week too, okay?
Even if you took a three week hiatus, it's okay.
Even if you did, you don't know why.
Just try again.
And I'm looking forward to eating Moco-chan's leftovers today too!
BAU BAU!
These are good.
Why is it so good today, huh?
No.
And today's Doggie of the Day!
Today's Doggie of the Day is... De-den!
Shi!
Shi as in sushi!
It's so cute!
This is a dog you found at the bar.
So you go to the bar to meet cute dogs, huh?
But, you know, this Ruffian says that she is the second ruffiest dog they've seen in their life.
Right?
That's pretty kind.
You didn't forget about us, huh?
So, you pet her.
How does she BAU BAU?
She.
You know like a... BAU BAU!
BAU BAU!
That's probably... Seductive BAU BAU!
The second fluffiest dog at the bar.
BAU BAU!
Cute dog.
Yeah, she is the kind of fluffy dog you find at the bar.
I guess she just lets anyone pet her, huh?
She's cute!
She's a cute dog!
Very fluffy!
BAU BAU!
For today I went on a walk!
We have...
De-den!
Oh, cute!
Those are some pretty dainty paw prints you found in your room there.
I like that.
Were they imprinted on the sidewalk?
Let's live forever and ever and ever.
Wait, are those in the sand?
Doesn't matter, I love it.
About FUWAMOCO's puppets, they're a little bit different compared to this.
But, well, maybe you'll find out one day.
It's a secret for now.
BAU BAU!
And for our Question of the Day, we have
De-den!
Hi, FUWAMOCO!
How long does it usually take to prepare an episode of FUWAMOCO Morning?
This is a really good question!
We've mentioned it a little bit before.
I think a while ago?
Yeah, probably a while ago.
But it actually takes us quite a while to prepare everything.
You know, there's a lot of work that you don't see, and, well, we don't really want you to see it either, you know, but, generally every day before FUWAMOCO Morning, we're up about three hours beforehand, you know, preparing, getting ready.
You know, it's also because it's proven that it takes your voice around three hours to fully wake up, too, but it takes us a while to prepare.
Yeah, if we kind of decide to rush, at the very least, it takes us around two hours to get everything done in time.
But, you know, we're constantly always trying to find new ways to make FUWAMOCO Morning more sustainable and a little bit easier on us.
But this is how it is for now.
I think it's gotten a bit better, too.
Yeah, I think it's gotten a bit better.
No matter how much of a commitment it is to us, it's really worth it to be able to see you off in the morning like this.
Hopefully, you know, we're able to help you start off your day on the right paw.
Exactly.
So, Ruffians,
Thank you.
Thank you for being here.
Yeah, for starting your day with us!
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you!
Thank you every single day.
And also, thank you for your submissions, your scoops, your FUWAMOCO scoops, your wonderful questions,
Pero Sighting.
Doggie of the Day.
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Let's continue to make FUWAMOCO Morning the warm place it is that we can share everything with.
BAU BAU!
Well, for our next theme,
We have de-den!
Tonight we're playing Escalator.
Yeah, it seems like it's kind of similar to the Exit.
It seems like we need to escape the escalator.
That's how I feel normally.
Ruffians, please join us because...
You know, Escalade is a little bit spooky to us, too.
Lots of teeth, tails, stuff to get caught.
Yeah, not very gentle, so... Please join us, okay?
BAU BAU!
And for FUWAMOCO, it'll be our first time watching Kanon 2006.
We did watch the Kanon 2002 a long time ago.
That was a long time ago though.
So, you know, it's gonna be kind of fresh for us.
Especially because we haven't seen Kanon 2006.
And we can't remember anymore.
So, you know, we hope that we can experience it all together!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Thank you for joining us today for another episode of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Momo!
BAU BAU!
Winkly!
Iki Asura.
BAU BAU!
Viva.
Ivan.
BAU BAU!
Togetsu.
Rushia.
BAU BAU!
Zagreer.
Tomato House.
BAU BAU!
Jamukou.
Slay Moon.
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!